Yeah market segmentation
is probably at the very,
very center of a go to market
strategy that's successful.
So first let's talk about
what is a market segment.
So a market segment is a group of
people that have two things in common.
One is a used case.
They have a common set of needs that
they would be fulfilling through
a product like yours or someone elses.
And secondly, and this is the one
people miss, they talk to each other.
So a segment is actually a unit of
conversation and therefore, and
the reason why that's so important is
if you can get your marketing message
circulating inside a segment,
the segment will circulate it for you.
No entrepreneur can afford to go out and
pay to address every prospect
that they want to sell to.
You have to have your
community selling for you.
But that means you have to be able to
model the boundaries of that community
and be able to aim your marketing
communications activities in
a way that that community embraces them
and it resonates inside that community.
So just to make that
point crystal clear.
When yo talk about your product,
your saying things that apply to many
communities, that will not
resonate inside a community.
When you talk about the specific needs
of that community in the language that
community talks to itself about even
when your not talking about you
now your going to resonate
with that community.
So this market segmentation
in that sense.
Is a communications vehicle to make sure
you talk the talk of the customer so
they can then walk the walk
with you going forward.
That's idea number one.
The second thing about market
segmentation and this is kind of a fun
experience you have if you've
been marketing for awhile.
Fun if you like learning with pain.
So, the idea is whenever
you think about a segment,
people usually draw a circle they say,
okay so we're targeting this segment.
And then inevitably somebody comes along
and says, what about this customer who's
right at the edge of the circle and
almost inside but not quite.
And then well you,
well okay we'll bring them in too.
And then well, we'll bring these
people in here, and then we'll bring.
And pretty soon there's just no
integrity in the process at all.
So what we've learned about segments
is you cannot define a segment
by its boundary.
because wherever you draw a line
there'll be somebody just on the other
side of that line who's pretty
darn close to the segment, right.
So what you do instead is you define
segments by their center points.
This is where they get this
idea called the poster child.
The poster child is
the perfect exemplar, the ideal
representation of the target customer
with the compelling reason to buy.
And that person, and often you create
something they call a persona,
which would be the embodiment
of that target customer, and
then you aim all of your marketing
communications at that one person
because they resonate with
all the people around them.
And furthermore you get your engineering
and you name, aim all of your
engineering at solving the use case
exactly the way that customer would like
it solved, and again that engineering
will resonate with people around, and so
therefore you can act on the world
in units of used cases and
word of mouth groups.
And so segmentation is designed to
allow you to leverage engineering
to the point where
the world is on your side.
As soon as you go outside the use
case and as soon as you go outside
the conversation group the world
is no longer working with you.
They may not be working against you,
but they're not working with you.
And as an entrepreneur,
at the beginning,
you desperately need
the world to work with you.
Eventually, if you become
a global standard,
then you don't need conversation groups.
Google does not need a conversation
group, it is a global standard.
But most of us are not Google, and
so particularly at the beginning.
And even at the beginning,
Google was not Google, so how do you
get started with those early groups?